síndrome de dolor regional complejo o
crp s por sus siglas en inglés
anteriormente conocido como distrofia
simpática refleja o rst por sus siglas
en inglés es una afección crónica que
causa dolor persistente y con ardor así
como hinchazón en los brazos manos
piernas o pies la respuesta normal de su
cuerpo a una lesión comienza cuando los
receptores del dolor transmiten mensajes
de dolor en forma de impulsos nerviosos
al cerebro una vez que estos impulsos
llegan a los centros de dolor en el
cerebro éstos generan nuevos impulsos y
los envían a través del sistema nervioso
simpático a la zona de la lesión los
impulsos simpáticos desencadenan una
respuesta inflamatoria que provoca la
expansión de los vasos sanguíneos la
respuesta inflamatoria también lleva a
la hinchazón y el enrojecimiento en el
tejido dañado a medida que su herida
cicatriza la hinchazón y el
enrojecimiento disminuyen y el dolor
desaparece sin embargo si usted padece
de síndrome de dolor regional complejo
el dolor y la hinchazón no desaparece
después de la cicatrización de la herida
y podría empeorar
tiempo aunque la causa exacta se
desconoce una teoría sugiere que después
de que la lesión se haya cicatrizado los
impulsos anormales continúan viajando a
lo largo de los nervios hacia su piel y
los vasos sanguíneos estimulando la
respuesta inflamatoria existen dos tipos
de síndrome de dolor regional complejo
aunque los síntomas son los mismos para
ambos si usted padece de sdr c1 su
afección puede haber sido provocada por
una enfermedad o lesión pero usted no
tiene una lesión del nervio en la zona
afectada si usted padece cr ps2 su
afección está claramente relacionada a
una lesión del nervio en la zona
afectada
el tratamiento del síndrome de dolor
regional complejo se centra en el
tratamiento del dolor ya que no hay cura
para esta afección las opciones de
tratamiento pueden incluir medicamentos
terapia física bloqueo nervioso
implantación de un dispositivo que
controla el dolor cirugía y apoyo
psicosocial